foreign
[Music]
welcome to a new episode of architecting
with Google Cloud
as a child I remember how I used to get
sad about not finding my favorite
chocolate in the grocery store near my
home now making the product available at
the right time at the right place is
still one of the fundamental challenges
retailers across the globe are trying to
solve imagine a technology which can
help you quickly identify out of stock
items in a retail store and replenish
that store with minimum disruption
ultimately helping you grow your
business sounds amazing right well
that's exactly what our guest today is
trying to solve for their clients I am
Manish Kumar a customer engineer at
Google Cloud
welcome to the show Vijay can you tell
us a bit about who you are what's your
background what you are doing at
infinite
well first of all uh thank you Manish
for
uh inviting me here as a part of your
show thanks to Google
a bit about myself I finished my PhD in
computer science around 2012 time frame
from IIT Bombay and then I joined IBM
research Labs where I was one of the
first Engineers to work on IBM Watson AI
platform
uh and then after a short stint at IBM
research I essentially started with
intellect
and infillect
um we are building one of the first
Enterprise SAS platforms for cpg retail
where we help our customers to make sure
that their
out of stock and overstocking problems
are essentially resolved
what we are really building is what we
call as a thermometer and a thermostat
which means it helps our customers to
measure and control their in-store on
shelf inventory so we work with the
likes of PNG or Kimberly Clark or
PepsiCo and what we help them with is
really to help them understand if their
products are kept at the right place in
retail stores at the right time and
displayed at the right price or not and
we do that by equipping their sales reps
with a very simple to use mobile
application where they go to the stores
they take photos and from those photos
we extract a lot of information about
what kind of skus are placed where are
they placed at the right position and
that helps these sales reps to fix out
of stock and overstocking issues in the
stores
today we have uh customers across over
16 countries we track anywhere between
uh 200 000 to 400 000 stores across the
globe and be processed over 25 million
photos each month so that's what we do
as a company wow that's amazing thanks
for sharing those details now this is
not an easy problem to solve how did you
first think about it well uh when we
started infinite we actually started
with a different idea our initial idea
what I call as a bold adventure uh we
embarked on a journey to build a b2c
platform or a b2c application so our
initial idea was to create a destination
for
and consumers like you and me uh where
you get the experience that's between
Pinterest and Amazon so if you go to
Pinterest today you see a catalog of
photos
um photos from Fashion or home decor or
lifestyle and when you go to Amazon you
basically see uh products that you can
shop
so what we felt was that a distinction
which is in between is
a missing which means you can shop from
pictures or videos
and that's what we embarked on to create
where consumers can just take pictures
or they input pictures from any of the
social media platforms and they get to
see the products that they can shop
um that's Adventure game really lasts
for too long for various reasons but
essentially we discovered that consumers
were taking photos inside this stores
with the intent of shopping the same
item on e-commerce platforms and we saw
pictures being taken off Lays chips
packets or PepsiCo bottles or even
alcohol products right
and hence we approached the cpj
manufacturers to help them understand
this is the behavior we are seeing in
the market how we can work together
and that's where they essentially
um told us that look today I don't
understand how my products are actually
positioned across a large number of
retail stores and if I have that data
with me I can very easily plug out of
stock and all stuff and problems and
that's where we built the whole product
the whole Tech platform where uh you
could take photos you can Empower and
enable sales reps of these cpg companies
to just take photos inside the stores
and get to understand in-store on shelf
metrics and more importantly fix the
issues essentially uh in real time right
so uh yeah it's it's been an uh
interesting Journey for us to do a pivot
but find the right problem to solve card
right so this is a very large problem
faced by retail industry today right uh
can you tell us more about how you are
solving it what are the different
products in your Suite sure so earlier
this problem was getting solved using
manual audits which means you send
people to the store these people have to
spend hours in front of the retail
shelves to actually count the facings of
the products uh to extract metrics like
share of shelf on shell visibility or
planogram compliance and so on and so
forth right and now if you see we are
bringing in a lot of automation through
AI technology and there are various
components to this AI technology right
from the the way we build our mobile
applications the way we do on device AI
uh the way we compress the photos and
send them to Cloud do the processing and
get the insights back to the Reps on the
ground sometimes we do processing on the
device itself because it helps these
reps to take photos and then get results
without even having internet connection
um and the same technology platform we
have applied to enable different
products today we have three different
products which we call interview with
infert nvi and infinite everything
starts with infy so we have three
different products and uh these
essentially help our customers which are
essentially cpg retail customers uh to
either improve their sales or to improve
their marketing or even we work with
last format retailers to help them
understand how to identify shrinkages as
the customers essentially use a checkout
counters right so yes we target from
sales to marketing to in-store
operations when we work with our
customers got it
um okay so now my favorite part of the
this discussion now that we know how
customers might use infilling let's Deep
dive bit into a user's Journey can you
please explain what happens when a store
agent clicks an image on the Shelf
sure so
as I explained we have three different
components at broad level where we have
mobile app for sales reps to take photos
in the store these photos are either
processed on the device itself or
sometimes they are uploaded to the cloud
and then essentially you process them in
the cloud and then we have an AI service
in the cloud which does a lot more
computations on these images
so
these three broad components come
together to enable a real-time service
where in the end for these reps it uh
looks like a magic to the end customers
right uh and as soon as they take photos
they essentially they get the response
back where they understand how to fix as
I said out of stock and overstocking and
that's essentially the
magic that we are trying to enable
now if you zoom in in each of these
components and perhaps I'll take example
of the web service as well as our AI
service so when you take a deep dive
into the web service especially because
we can get a lot of photos from a lot of
different geographies from a lot of
stores there is a very key component of
how do we ingest these images while
balancing the load
um on our servers and that's where we
make use of a lot of load balancing
models as a part of gcp platform now
once these photos are received by our
web service we need to get these photos
processed if not at least store them and
retrieve them for anything that we need
to do in future and that's why we use
cloud Pub sub kind of module which
makes sure that these images are stored
they are essentially sent to our AI
service
and the whole automation bit is
essentially kicked in and then we use
cloud SQL as well as bigquery because
in the end we have to generate value for
our customers so when these images are
processed and if you think about it if
we get 50 million photos then from each
image we are probably generating about
1000 different sample points right so
it's a a huge data that we need to store
that we need to make sense out of and we
need to make actionable insights
available to our stakeholders and that's
where platforms like Cloud SQL or
bigquery uh they essentially help us to
manage the entire load right
and now if you zoom into the uh AI
service part where we need to get all of
these images processed right
um in our AI pipeline at any point in
time we have anywhere between 1 to 50
models right the 1 to 50 deep learning
based models which are essentially
working in Tandem and there too we have
the same components that we have applied
where load balancing or how do you make
sure that the right a micro service is
essentially getting the right kind of
image to be processed we extensively use
kubernetes kind of platform because when
we get very high load uh we need to make
sure that the whole compute module
goes up and down uh basically provision
the right number of gpus to get the
photos processed right so uh there are a
lot of these components like kubernetes
and gpus that we use on the gcp platform
that helps us to process these photos in
real time and then eventually enable
that whole experience of a magic to uh
our end customers no that's amazing
thank you for taking us through that I'm
sure the journey to get here has its own
ups and downs can you maybe highlight
any challenges you might have faced as
you went through your journey yeah sure
so
um bit you know anytime we need to
enable this a magical experience there
are very hard technical problems that we
need to solve uh I can maybe talk about
a three different problems uh so one
problem that we faced was how do we
enable on device AI right because uh not
every phone comes with a very powerful
CPU or GPU right and uh that's where we
used tensorflow based systems where
um we could train a very small size but
very accurate models that we deployed as
a part of the Android applications and
that really helped us to enable
experiences where there are many times I
mean right from South Korea to us I have
seen that there is not enough Internet
available to upload the photos and uh
having these on device models
essentially helps us to still give a
good experience to Consumers where they
can see things happening in real time
and yet the the entire processing is
happening on the device itself second
thing I can talk about is uh we made use
of some of the beta services like a
Vertex AI where we made use of the
knowledge graph that is prepared by
Google over probably last 25 years if
not more and that really helped us to
understand how do we create
Master data of all these queues that are
available across the world because in
the end any kind of AI Works where you
have to show it a reference pattern and
those kinds of reference patterns we
could extract from Google's
AI service
and lastly I would say there are a lot
of Google uh
Cloud Vision apis that we use which
which essentially augment uh the kind of
In-House IP that we are developing right
so uh
um I mean the challenges faced where
right from how do we make use of low end
phones to enable on device AI to how do
we quickly identify uh the entire
product Master for a customer to how do
we rapidly customize our AI platform uh
to index all the skus of our customer
right and in
you know all of these challenges uh I
must say that we have used some of the
platforms and modules that Google has
built and has generously made open uh
for a service like ours to make use of
them always good to hear that thank you
Vijay for sharing what happens behind
the scenes what can we expect to see
from intellect and near future
for there are a lot of uh interesting
product roadmap uh that we have uh you
know in the end
um we want to make sure that our
platforms are always the fastest in the
market to be set up always the fastest
to get the responses back to our
consumers uh they also are affordable to
customers which means uh the more we
invest as a part of building uh the core
IP the more it is going to be cost
effective for our customers and there
are several other products that we are
developing I only talked about in few
ways as our product but then there is
infinity art and then in VI where we
target uh marketing as well as in-store
operational divisions of our customers
so
um how do we apply the existing AI
platform that we have built how do we
Compound on that and how do we enable
different experiences for our customers
that's something that uh I've got quite
keen on to get to Market
wow we can't wait to see what you build
next thank you Vijay for coming to our
show where can our viewers go and learn
more about infinite oh well you can go
to uh
www.inflict.com uh uh we have a lot of
case studies for our customers we have
lot of interesting blogs where uh if you
want to understand more about our
product or about technology
you can get to do so uh since I have an
opportunity uh if you know if you're
looking at joining a startup which is
growing very fast in the market and
solving very hardcore technical problems
uh are those are always open we are
hiring for all sorts of roles uh not
just for engineering but also puzzles
and marketing uh so we would love to
have you uh as a part of our chatting
awesome thanks Vijay it was pleasure to
have you with us today hey thanks Manish
and thanks to Google so the next time
when you are doing your weekly shopping
in the neighborhood grocery store to get
your favorite snack and you always find
them stocked up there thanks Vijay and
his team at intellect if you like the
content please share and subscribe to
our Channel where we continue to bring
you such awesome Tech stories till the
next episode thanks for watching and
take care
foreign
[Music]